c'est officiel le département des
yvelines a débloqué 1,5 million d'euros
pour financer la recherche et le
développement d'un nouveau
supercalculateur le bénéficiaire la
société atos bull l'entreprise implantée
aux clayes-sous-bois va pouvoir
développer cette machine du futur dans
ses locaux cette entreprise bull devenu
atos est une des perles du département
c'est un lieu
où s'exerce une compétition mondiale
particulièrement exacerbée et notre
travail d'élus c'est pas de faire de la
recherche à leur place c'est pas de leur
dire ce qu'ils doivent chercher bien
entendu on en est incapable c'est de
leur faciliter la vie pour qu'ils
puissent exercer leurs fonctions de
chercheur du mieux possible
les industriels ont besoin de soutien
dans leur dans leurs démarches en fait
ça crée un tissu disons de collaboration
et de partenariat qui nous permettent en
fait d'avancé la machine devrait être
capable d'effectuer un milliard de
milliards d'opérations simultanées une
première elle permettra de stocker
calculer et analyser des masses de
données informatiques le projet sequana
c'est un projet majeur en fait dans
notre axe de recherche et développement
nous développons cette plateforme en
fait qui est un super calculateur qui
s'inscrit en fait d'allier dans la
lignée des supers lac calculateur que
nous avons déjà développé ce programme
va nous projeter en fait dans l'oeuf une
rupture dans les prochaines vingt
prochaines années en parallèle le
soutien du conseil départemental
permettra de financer un nouveau data
center un centre de stockage de données
dernière génération sur le site
historique du groupe atos bull les
premiers travaux sont prévus pour
l'année prochaine